PNG files represent the bulk
of Android image content,
especially if you've
got a lot of UI elements
in your application,
rather than photo data.
But PNG files also
represent a huge problem
in terms of file size.
They're easy to bloat,
and too often, we
don't give them enough
attention to make them smaller.
My name is Colt
McAnlis, and ensuring
that your app is
easy to distribute,
and that images are quick
to grab from your server
has everything to do with
taking a really hard look at how
you're using PNG files.
Let's take a look at how bad
this problem is, in reality.
Take this simple, 16
by 16 pixel red square.
The default exported
image from Photoshop
creates a 2.7 k image,
where the one that's
been processed with some
attention to the file size
only ends up being 121 bytes.
The point here is
straightforward--
if you're serving
a load of PNG files
to your app that haven't been
optimized to this degree,
you're going to be wasting a
lot of your users' bandwidth.
See, at its core, PNGs
are simple file formats
that apply a
lossless compression
algorithm to the pixel data.
The end result is that
your image maintains
100% of its original
quality, but as a trade off,
means that the image can be
bloated in terms of file size.
Other formats,
like JPEG, achieve
better compression
[? radios ?] than PNG
by applying a lossy compression
algorithm to the pixels, which
reduces the number of
unique pixels in the image,
before handing it off
to the lossless stages.
This first step of reducing
image quality helps
make the pixel data more
compressible to the lossless
encoder, and also allows
you, the content creator,
to make a decision-- do you
want better image quality,
or do you want
smaller file sizes?
Sadly, PNG's simple
file format doesn't
come equipped with the ability
to apply a lossy preprocess
to the pixel data.
But this doesn't
give you an excuse
to use these bloated
PNGs in your apps.
With a little bit of
gusto and elbow grease,
you too can easily incorporate
a lossy preprocessor
to your PNG pipeline,
helping reduce
the bloat in these files.
See, the problem that
we're solving here really
isn't a new one.
I mean, cleaning up PNG
files to be less bloated
and applying a lossy
preprocess is an issue that's
been around awhile.
A simple Google
search proves that.
I mean, when you do,
you get a plethora
of tools that are already
available to help accomplish
these same tasks on your behalf.
Now, most of these
tools are command line
driven, so that they fit into
your existing build systems,
or they've been
ported to languages
that are easy to adapt
to your content servers.
In fact, Script
PNG will allow you
to run a bunch of different
compression codecs
on your image
file, and see which
one gives the best
compression ratio
for the right visual quality.
Basically, it'll do
all the work of finding
the sweet spot between
compression and quality
for you.
And in reality, there's lots of
situations where you shouldn't
be using PNG files at all.
I mean, if you don't
need transparency,
a JPEG file with carefully
tuned compression settings
would be much more
valuable to you.
Or if you do need
transparency, consider
storing the transparent channel
in a separate JPEG file, which
you then combine back into the
alpha channel of your image
at a load time
point in the future.
This will help reduce
the overall footprint
of the alpha channel,
since it can usually
be compressed much
better than the RBG data
by the JPEG algorithm.
Of course, if you want
transparency, animation,
and great compression, you
could just use the WebP format.
WebP is an open source
image format from Google
that supports alpha
transparency, lossless,
and lossy compression,
as well as animation.
The entire purpose
of this image format
is to be a one stop
image format shop
for developers of all sizes.
And the good news is that
WebP is natively supported
in Android, as of 4.2.1.
Well, technically, a bit earlier
than that, but all the good
bells and whistles landed
in 4.2.1, which is basically
SDK 17 and higher,
accounting for 67%
of the total global market
presence of Android,
as of the filming
of the episode.
Of course, that'll change
in like 10 minutes.
And that's actually a large
portion of the market,
so don't be afraid to
experiment with WebP
where it makes sense to.
But in truth, WebP and
lossy preprocessing steps
will only help you with
the size of your image
during distribution.
Once the image is
loaded into memory,
they're decompressed into
their regular format,
so that they can be used
for rendering, meaning
that all the file
compression only
helps you with data transfer,
not CPU memory residency.
That's a whole separate topic.
But distribution
sizes are the smallest
of your worries, which is
why you should check out
the rest of the Android
Performance Patterns content.
And don't forget to join the G+
community for other great tips
from developers just like you.
So keep calm, profile your
code, and always remember--
perf matters.